Février 1945.
Depuis six ans, l'Europe est
un gigantesque champ de bataille.
Des millions d'hommes sont morts.
Mais cette fois, la certitude de
vaincre l'Allemagne nazie est enfin là
et les Alliés pensent déjà à l'avenir.
Car c'est maintenant, tandis
que les combats font encore rage,
qu'il faut préparer la paix.
Staline, Roosevelt et Churchill
vont donc décider de se réunir.
Cette rencontre aura lieu
dans une petite station balnéaire
du sud de l'Union soviétique.
C'est là, en Crimée,
que les trois géants
vont imaginer ensemble
le monde de l'après-guerre
lors de l'une des plus grandes
conférences de tous les temps,
la conférence de Yalta.
De Yalta, l'histoire a retenu cette photo.
Mais quel chemin
parcouru pour en arriver là ?
Pourquoi ces visages tendus
chez Churchill, Roosevelt et Staline ?
Unis dans la guerre, les Alliés vont
se révéler divisés et rivaux dans la paix.
Pendant huit jours,
du 4 au 11 février 1945,
les trois grands vont
se livrer une lutte sans merci,
tant leurs intérêts
et leurs idéologies les opposent.
À Yalta, c'est la dernière fois
qu'ils se verront tous ensemble.
Chacun d'eux est alors
à un moment crucial de son propre destin,
tandis qu'avec cette conférence,
le monde va bientôt sombrer
dans de nouvelles ténèbres.
3 février 1945.
Après sept heures de vol,
des avions américains et britanniques,
partis dans la nuit,
atterrissent sur le sol gelé
de l'aéroport de Saki, en Crimée.
À sa descente de l'avion,
Winston Churchill est ankylosé.
Il a 39 de fièvre.
Mais le Premier ministre
britannique donne le change.
Même malade, il est prêt
à écrire une nouvelle page de l'histoire.
Franklin Roosevelt, le président
américain, lui aussi, est prêt,
malgré une fatigue extrême.
Sur la piste, diplomates
et militaires se saluent.
À Yalta, nombre d'entre eux
vont tenir des journaux de bord.
Grâce à leurs confidences,
nous savons ce qui s'est réellement
passé pendant cette conférence.
Leurs écrits racontent tout ce que
l'histoire officielle ne mentionne pas.
Staline n'a pas daigné
venir accueillir ses hôtes à Saki.
Son absence est déjà une manière
de jouer le rapport de force.
Les négociations ont bel et bien commencé.
C'est donc Molotov, le fidèle
bras droit du dirigeant soviétique,
qui attend Roosevelt
et Churchill au pied de l'avion.
Rongé par la poliomyélite,
Roosevelt ne peut plus marcher.
À pied à ses côtés, Churchill
semble en position d'infériorité.
L'étrangeté de cette scène
n'échappe pas à Lord Moran,
le médecin personnel de Churchill,
qui s'offusque dans son journal.
« Le Premier ministre suivait
à pied, aux côtés du président,
comme lorsque,
dans ses dernières années,
un intendant indien accompagnait
la diligence de la reine Victoria. »
Et ce n'est pas
la dernière fois qu'en Crimée
Churchill apparaîtra
comme l'intendant de Roosevelt.
Car déjà, alors que
la guerre n'est toujours pas achevée,
l'Empire britannique
a perdu de sa superbe.
Les États-Unis et l'Union soviétique
sont les deux nouveaux géants du siècle.
À Yalta, Churchill va
devoir se battre pour exister.
Yalta est à 150 kilomètres de Saki.
Il ne faut pas moins
de cinq heures pour y parvenir,
tant la route est mauvaise et sinueuse.
Pour Roosevelt,
une nouvelle épreuve commence.
Il était paralysé.
Pour voyager en automobile,
il devait s'asseoir à l'arrière
avec deux coussins
derrière lui pour corseter son dos
et soutenir ses jambes
qui étaient devenues totalement inutiles.
C'était véritablement
un voyage très difficile.
Alors que la guerre continue
sur le continent européen,
le parcours a été placé
sous haute surveillance.
160 avions de combat sillonnent le ciel.
Anna Boettiger, la fille de Roosevelt
qui l'accompagne dans ce voyage,
est stupéfaite de voir les moyens
déployés par les Soviétiques.
Dans son journal, elle écrit :
« Tout au long
de la route entre Saki et Yalta,
des soldats avaient été
postés tous les 300 mètres.
À chaque fois
qu'une voiture passait devant eux,
ceux qui n'avaient pas de fusil
nous adressaient un salut.
Tous ces soldats russes, femmes
comprises, étaient chics et droits. »
Par la fenêtre, Roosevelt et Churchill
découvrent un spectacle de désolation.
La Crimée a été reprise
aux Allemands il y a un an à peine.
Près de 20 millions
de Russes ont perdu la vie.
70 000 villes et villages
soviétiques ont été anéantis.
L'URSS a été
profondément meurtrie par la guerre.
Et Staline a lui-même supervisé
l'itinéraire de ses hôtes
afin qu'aucune destruction
ne leur échappe.
Ça permettra à Staline,
et ça, c'est bien sûr son habileté,
d'une certaine manière,
de culpabiliser ses deux interlocuteurs,
Roosevelt en premier.
Nous avons beaucoup de morts, sous entendu
car vous n'êtes pas venus nous sauver.
Après cinq heures
d'un interminable trajet,
Roosevelt et Churchill arrivent
enfin à Yalta en début de soirée.
Roosevelt est épuisé.
Pour lui, le voyage a commencé
12 jours auparavant,
lorsqu'il a traversé l'Atlantique en
bateau avant de prendre l'avion à Malte.
Au total, le président américain
a parcouru 8 500 kilomètres,
Churchill 3 200,
et Staline,
venu en train, seulement 1 500.
Comme si le nombre
de kilomètres avait un sens
et que Roosevelt était celui
qui était prêt à faire le plus d'efforts,
Staline le moins.
La baie de Yalta
n'a rien perdu de son charme.
Au XIXᵉ siècle, c'était une
sorte de Riviera soviétique
où tsars et aristocrates
venaient en villégiature.
Les participants
à la conférence vont être accueillis
dans des palais
restés intacts aujourd'hui.
Avant que les négociations
ne s'ouvrent en février 1945,
ils avaient été entièrement restaurés.
En prévision de la conférence,
il y a eu un réameublement très rapide
de choses qui sont venues
de Moscou par convois entiers
pour rendre un aspect
hospitalier à tous ces palais
qui avaient souffert d'un terrible
défaut d'entretien depuis très longtemps.
Staline a imposé le choix de Yalta.
Il veut donc que ses hôtes
n'aient pas à le regretter.
Il va les recevoir avec magnificence.
Il leur a réservé
les deux plus belles villas.
Le palais Livadia pour Roosevelt.
C'est ici que se sont déroulées
les négociations.
Et la villa Vorontsov pour Churchill.
Ce soir-là,
la nuit est claire sur Yalta.
Chacun des trois grands prend des
forces pour le marathon qui s'annonce.
4 février 1945.
Premier jour des négociations.
Avant que les débats ne commencent,
Staline effectue une visite
de courtoisie à ses hôtes.
À Churchill d'abord.
Les deux hommes ne se sont pas vus depuis
quatre mois lors d'une rencontre à Moscou.
Ils sont heureux de se retrouver et
font le point sur la situation militaire.
Les retrouvailles avec Roosevelt
sont, elles aussi, chaleureuses.
Le Russe et l'Américain partagent
un Martini, le péché mignon de Roosevelt.
Et il manque le citron.
Staline en prend note,
et la fois d'après, effectivement,
il fait amener un gigantesque citronnier.
Ça les impressionne,
parce que pour les Anglais
comme pour les Américains,
un citronnier entier, en pleine
guerre, et au mois de février,
c'est quelque chose de fabuleux.
Ils sont donc littéralement éblouis.
Et, en même temps, ça sert
à montrer la puissance de Staline.
Car sur le terrain,
Staline est en position de force.
Depuis le printemps, le rouleau
compresseur soviétique est en marche
et l'Armée rouge reprend
des territoires aux Allemands.
Pour Staline, l'heure de monnayer
son effort de guerre est venue.
À 17h00,
les négociations commencent enfin.
Dans la salle de bal du Livadia,
aménagée pour la conférence,
tout est prêt.
Ministres et diplomates discutent entre
eux en attendant les trois grands.
Churchill est le premier
à arriver au Livadia avec sa fille Sarah.
Le Premier ministre est de bonne humeur
et coiffé d'une toque russe
pour faire honneur à son hôte.
Il va mieux.
Après une bonne nuit de
sommeil, la fièvre est tombée.
Staline arrive à sa suite.
Devant les caméras,
les deux hommes affichent leur complicité.
Roosevelt, lui, s'est déjà installé à la
table de négociation en toute discrétion.
Le même manège se répétera
les jours suivants.
Il a interdit qu'on filme ses
arrivées, jugées trop humiliantes.
Il devait être transporté de sa chaise
roulante jusqu'à une autre chaise.
Ce qui n'est pas facile quand vous
êtes paralysé à partir de la taille.
Les conseillers particuliers des trois
grands prennent place autour d'eux.
Car ils ne vont pas négocier seuls.
Churchill est accompagné d'Anthony Eden,
son ministre des Affaires étrangères,
ainsi que du diplomate Alexander
Cadogan, spécialiste de la Pologne.
Roosevelt, lui, va s'appuyer sur
Harry Hopkins, son bras droit et ami,
l'homme en qui il a le plus confiance,
mais aussi sur Edward Statinius,
son ministre des Affaires étrangères.
Staline a deux conseillers principaux :
Viatcheslav Molotov,
son ministre des Affaires étrangères,
et le diplomate Ivan Maïsky.
Quatre gros dossiers sont sur la table :
le sort de l'Allemagne vaincue,
celui de la Pologne,
l'ONU et la guerre contre le Japon.
Sur tous ces dossiers, la position
des différentes armées alliées
va jouer un rôle déterminant.
Depuis le mois de décembre,
l'Armée rouge a libéré la Roumanie,
la Bulgarie, la Hongrie et la Pologne.
Les Russes ne sont plus
qu'à 80 kilomètres de Berlin.
Ralenties par une
contre-offensive allemande,
les troupes anglo-américaines,
elles, n'ont toujours pas franchi le Rhin.
On peut dire que
du point de vue militaire,
les Soviétiques sont nettement
en avance par rapport aux Occidentaux
et, de ce point de vue-là,
tiennent le haut du pavé,
ce qui peut avoir des conséquences
du point de vue diplomatique.
En plus de cette asymétrie sur le terrain,
il en existe une autre, idéologique.
Churchill et Roosevelt sont
deux capitalistes face à un communiste.
Pourtant, ils ne vont pas nécessairement
faire front commun contre Staline.
Au contraire.
Car en fait, les deux hommes sont assez
éloignés idéologiquement l'un de l'autre.
Roosevelt apprécie Churchill,
parce que c'est le vieux cheval de guerre,
parce qu'il a tenu seul en Europe en 1940,
et qu'il admire ce type qui est encore
capable de performances extraordinaires,
et, en même temps, un certain mépris,
parce qu'il considère que c'est
un vieux colonialiste antédiluvien,
alors que lui considère
qu'il a des idées modernes,
notamment la décolonisation du monde.
Roosevelt a besoin
de Staline plus que de Churchill.
Car au même moment dans le Pacifique,
les Américains sont
en guerre contre le Japon.
Les combats sont d'une violence inouïe
et les Japonais n'hésitent pas à
envoyer des avions kamikazes sur l'ennemi
plutôt que de se rendre.
Sans l'aide des Soviétiques,
la guerre risque de s'éterniser.
Roosevelt compte aussi sur Staline
pour participer à la future
Organisation des Nations Unies,
qu'il veut mettre en place.
Sans l'URSS,
l'ONU ne sera qu'une coquille vide.
Pour faire avancer son projet,
Roosevelt est prêt à sacrifier Churchill.
C'est un allié acquis
qui n'a rien à lui apporter.
Churchill le vit très mal.
Il sait très bien
que Staline va exploiter à mort
toute divergence
entre les Anglais et les Américains.
Donc pour lui,
c'est absolument désastreux.
Car le Premier ministre britannique
soupçonne Staline de vouloir installer
des régimes communistes dans
tous les pays libérés par l'Armée rouge.
Sans l'aide de Roosevelt,
Churchill sait qu'il n'aura pas
les moyens de l'en empêcher.
Lors de cette première journée, seules
les questions militaires sont abordées.
Chacun s'observe.
Dans le jeu tactique qui débute,
Staline prend immédiatement la main.
Il propose que Roosevelt
préside les séances plénières.
En le mettant comme président,
quelque part, on le flatte,
mais aussi, on le réduit
un peu à l'impuissance,
parce qu'il va être obligé
de servir un peu de maître de cérémonie.
Et pendant ce temps-là,
on pourra observer, on pourra réfléchir,
on pourra négocier
un peu derrière son dos.
C'est très astucieux
de la part de Staline.
Cette première séance
de négociations était un tour de chauffe.
Rien d'important ne s'y décide,
mais les Occidentaux ont compris
qu'il ne serait pas facile de faire
entendre leur voix face à Staline.
Alors, dans la soirée, chacun
affûte sa stratégie pour le lendemain.
Churchill réfléchit seul et au calme,
admirant les peintures
d'aristocrates britanniques
que Staline a eu l'attention d'accrocher
aux murs pour lui faire plaisir.
Roosevelt, lui, élabore son plan de
bataille en compagnie de Harry Hopkins.
Deuxième jour.
Churchill arrive à nouveau le premier,
tandis que Staline se fait
une fois de plus désirer.
Cette fois, les choses
sérieuses vont commencer.
La question de l'Allemagne est en débat.
Quel sort réserver à l'Allemagne
une fois qu'elle aura perdu la guerre ?
Comment l'administrer ?
Quelles réparations exiger ?
Sur toutes ces questions,
les Alliés ont des positions différentes.
Les discussions débutent
sur le problème de sa future occupation.
Depuis 1944,
il était prévu qu'une fois vaincu,
le pays serait divisé
et administré en trois zones :
américaine, britannique et soviétique.
Mais voilà que Churchill
réclame une quatrième zone...
pour la France.
Il ne veut plus être seul
contre ces deux géants
qui en veulent un peu
aux empires coloniaux.
Il veut donc avoir cette complicité
avec une autre puissance coloniale.
Staline finalement, bon prince, va dire :
les Français ne se sont pas
vraiment battus pendant la guerre.
On ne voit pas pourquoi.
Ils ont collaboré.
Ils ont cédé très vite en 1940.
Ils ne le méritent pas.
Mais enfin, d'accord,
mais alors, vous la prenez
sur vos zones d'occupation à vous.
La concession ne lui coûte rien.
Staline cède rapidement.
Mais il en profite pour demander
un effort à ses alliés, en contrepartie.
Il veut obtenir le maximum
de réparations de la part de l'Allemagne.
L'URSS est ruinée.
Les Boches doivent payer.
Cette perspective revancharde
effraie Roosevelt et Churchill.
Et cette fois-ci, les deux
Occidentaux se serrent les coudes.
Si on pille l'Allemagne et qu'on affame
l'Allemagne pour faire plaisir à Staline,
comment est-ce qu'on la relève après ?
Ce sera forcément sur nos fonds à nous,
et c'est nous qui allons payer
pour les réparations de Staline.
Donc c'est mauvais, c'est pas bon.
Devant ce refus, Staline se braque.
Vexé, il devient suspicieux.
Le Soviétique s'en prend
à ses alliés et se montre agressif.
Franchement,
regardez-moi dans les yeux.
Pourquoi ne voulez-vous pas
la reconstruction de l'URSS ?
Est-ce qu'il n'y a pas des arrière-pensées
de votre côté, vous, Occidentaux,
à ne pas vouloir la reconstruction
légitime de notre pays ?
Pourquoi voulez-vous
affaiblir notre pays ?
Voilà pour la menace.
Maintenant, le bluff.
Staline va sortir le grand jeu.
Et pour cela, il va s'appuyer
sur son complice Molotov
avec lequel il forme un duo sans pareil.
Les deux hommes sont des maîtres
dans l'art de la diplomatie.
Molotov, c'est la version dure,
c'est monsieur "niet".
C'est celui qui n'est pas rigolo,
qui va en général rester
sur les positions les plus dures.
Et, en général, le moment
où Staline intervient,
ça va être pour assouplir les angles,
pour dire : « Enfin,
tu exagères ! Pourquoi être si dur ? »
Dans le dossier allemand,
il faut à présent avancer un chiffre
pour le montant des réparations.
Rien n'a été décidé
par la délégation soviétique.
Seuls un minimum
et un maximum ont été envisagés.
Dans son journal, le diplomate
russe Ivan Maïsky raconte la scène.
« Molotov, qui était assis
à la droite de Staline,
se penche vers lui
et lui demande, inquiet :
Dois-je donner un montant ?
-Oui, donne le montant,
rétorque Staline.
-Lequel ? Cinq ou dix ?
-Dix, tranche Staline. »
C'est une manière de montrer
qu'on est en discussion,
que rien n'est totalement décidé,
et donc tout ça paraît plus rassurant
pour les interlocuteurs qui sont en face.
10 milliards pour l'Union soviétique.
Ça passe.
Personne ne dit rien.
Staline considère alors
que le montant est accepté.
Les Occidentaux n'ont pas osé réagir.
Mais cette décision aura
de lourdes conséquences par la suite.
Car face à une Allemagne
incapable de payer une telle somme,
les Soviétiques se dédommageront en nature
et démantèleront l'industrie allemande.
Après ce premier round de négociations,
chacun des trois grands se retire
dans son palais pour souffler.
Comme à son habitude,
Staline se plonge dans les dossiers
et prépare les débats du lendemain.
À son bureau, aujourd'hui encore,
tout est resté en l'état.
Au palais Livadia, Roosevelt, lui,
trouve un peu de repos et de
sérénité auprès de sa fille Anna.
Depuis quelques années,
elle est devenue sa confidente,
et Roosevelt l'emmène partout avec lui.
Elle n'offrait pas seulement la compagnie
agréable d'une fille pour son père.
Elle était très
au courant des dossiers.
Nous habitions
à la Maison-Blanche à cette époque
et je dirais qu'elle était plutôt
une sorte d'assistante personnelle
qui n'était pas payée.
C'était un peu son bras droit.
À 15 kilomètres de là, au Vorontsov,
Churchill est avec sa fille Sarah.
La jeune femme est comédienne
et, depuis la guerre,
elle est auxiliaire volontaire
dans la Royal Air Force.
Churchill aime
cette présence joyeuse à ses côtés.
Les filles sont ravies de participer.
À la fois, eux sont très contents
de montrer leurs filles en uniforme
pour montrer
que toute la famille participe,
et, en même temps,
c'est très bien vu de l'entourage.
On peut leur faire faire des choses
qu'on n'ose pas faire soi-même.
Par exemple, Churchill a
tendance à se lever très tard
parce qu'il travaille dans son lit.
Il est tout le temps dans son bain
et on ne peut pas envoyer un aide de camp
pour le sortir de son lit
ou de son bain. C'est impossible.
Par contre, on peut envoyer sa fille.
Le soir, comme pendant
presque toute la semaine,
les trois grands vont s'inviter à dîner.
L'occasion de poursuivre les
négociations de manière moins formelle.
Le premier de ces dîners
a lieu au Livadia.
Les Américains assurent le service,
mais les Russes ont fourni la nourriture.
Et Staline a mis un point d'honneur
à ce que tout soit grandiose.
Vous avez des dîners à 15, 20 ou 30 plats,
avec du caviar,
des esturgeons, de la crème...
La crème est rationnée en Angleterre,
on ne sait même plus ce que c'est.
On a oublié.
Entre temps, le peuple
soviétique crève de faim,
mais ça n'a aucune
importance pour Staline.
Le tout, c'est
de leur montrer sa puissance.
C'est la munificence géorgienne et russe.
C'est : je peux tout.
En tant qu'hôte,
demandez ce que vous voulez.
Psychologiquement,
ça donne un énorme ascendant.
Je suis votre maître, mais,
en même temps, je suis votre serviteur.
C'est beau et à la fois menaçant.
Donc ça fait qu'on dépend entièrement
de la bonne volonté de Staline.
C'est ça, Yalta, entre autres.
Pour que ses hôtes se sentent à l'aise et
dans de bonnes dispositions à son égard,
Staline a tout prévu.
À table, l'alcool coule à flots.
On sait très bien que
si on veut qu'une négociation aboutisse,
il faut que l'interlocuteur
soit en confiance.
Et la boisson, ça fait partie,
depuis toujours,
des moyens qui sont mis à disposition
de la puissance invitante.
Et là, il y a tout un jeu,
à savoir qui va boire le plus.
L'alcool a joué un rôle
à Yalta, c'est clair.
Ce premier dîner a rapproché les Alliés.
La confiance s'est installée.
Les négociations commencent
sous de nouveaux auspices.
Afin que tout le monde
puisse récupérer de ces soirées arrosées,
les séances plénières ont lieu
en fin d'après-midi.
Mais dans la matinée, les collaborateurs
de Staline, Roosevelt et Churchill
sont, eux, au travail
pour préparer les débats.
Ils imaginent des compromis
possibles sur les différents dossiers.
Aux trois grands, ensuite, de trancher.
Au troisième jour de négociations,
le 6 février,
le dossier polonais arrive sur la table.
C'est le plus épineux de la conférence.
C'est aussi le plus symbolique, car c'est
en Pologne que la guerre a commencé.
Les Alliés doivent mettre
sur pied un nouveau gouvernement.
Mais ils ne sont d'accord sur rien.
Depuis toujours, Staline
considère que la Pologne
représente un danger pour son pays.
Car au cours de l'histoire,
c'est toujours par la Pologne
que la Russie a été envahie.
Staline veut donc
que la Pologne devienne un pays ami.
En fait, il souhaite
constituer un glacis protecteur
tout autour de l'Union soviétique
afin qu'elle ne soit plus jamais attaquée.
Les Soviétiques voulaient
des États tampons.
Tout le monde savait que, pour les Russes,
c'était un point central
de leur politique étrangère.
Et quand vous y réfléchissez,
si vous étiez un grand pays
comme l'URSS l'était,
vous ne voudriez pas avoir
des États hostiles à vos frontières.
Vous souhaiteriez des États amis.
Mais qu'est-ce qu'un pays ami ?
Est-ce que c'est un pays ami
qui a simplement une politique extérieure
amicale à l'égard de l'Union soviétique
et qui, en politique intérieure,
est complètement libre ?
Ou est-ce qu'un pays ami,
de fil en aiguille,
est un pays qui va être communisé ?
C'est là la grande question.
Pour les Britanniques,
pas question d'avoir déclaré
la guerre à Hitler à cause de la Pologne
pour qu'elle devienne communiste.
À l'issue du conflit,
Churchill veut que la Pologne
devienne libre et indépendante.
La Grande-Bretagne était
traditionnellement amie avec la Pologne.
Les Anglais faisaient beaucoup
de commerce avec les Polonais.
Ils ne voulaient pas qu'un pays
aussi important que la Pologne,
en termes de commerce
et de potentiel humain,
passe sous domination communiste
s'ils pouvaient l'éviter.
Pour Roosevelt, loin d'Europe,
la question polonaise est plus accessoire.
Mais elle a tout de même
son importance, pour d'autres raisons.
Il y a 6 milions de citoyens américains
qui sont d'origine polonaise.
Et ces citoyens américains votent
pour la plupart démocrates,
c'est-à-dire pour le parti de Roosevelt.
Il est donc très sensible
à ce qui peut se passer en Pologne.
Ces citoyens polonais
réfugiés aux États-Unis
sont farouchement anticommunistes.
La plupart d'entre eux
sont arrivés en Amérique
avant la Première Guerre mondiale,
mais ils n'ont pas oublié qu'en 1939
Staline s'était entendu
avec Hitler pour envahir la Pologne.
Ces Polonais d'Amérique,
tout comme les Britanniques,
soutiennent le président polonais
Władysław Raczkiewicz,
en exil à Londres depuis 1940.
Le problème, c'est que face à lui,
il existe un autre gouvernement,
communiste cette fois.
Ce gouvernement sous influence
soviétique est dirigé par Boleslav Bierut.
Il est implanté au beau milieu
de la Pologne, à Lublin,
et se fait appeler le Comité de Lublin.
Le gouvernement de Londres
et celui de Lublin se haïssent.
Car il y a six mois,
l'irréparable entre eux s'est produit.
Août 1944.
À ce moment-là, l'Armée rouge est
aux portes de Varsovie.
Raczkiewicz, à Londres, décide
de déclencher l'insurrection.
Il veut que les résistants
libèrent eux-mêmes la capitale polonaise
avant les communistes, afin de garder
la mainmise sur le futur gouvernement.
Mais la riposte allemande est féroce.
Pendant 63 jours,
les résistants sont décimés.
Sciemment, Staline laisse faire et
ordonne à l'Armée rouge de ne pas bouger.
200 000 Polonais
sont massacrés par les Nazis.
La capitale polonaise
est détruite à plus de 90%.
Deux mois plus tard,
Staline vient cueillir le fruit mûr
et installe un gouvernement
communiste à Varsovie.
À Yalta, le comportement
de Staline pèse dans les négociations.
Churchill n'a jamais digéré
que le Soviétique ait laissé périr
les résistants de Varsovie
sans leur venir en aide.
Là, il a compris qu'il n'avait pas
affaire à un bon tonton bienveillant,
et qu'on ne pouvait donc
lui faire qu'une confiance très limitée,
qu'il avait affaire à un bandit dangereux,
et que, finalement, même s'il fallait
se débarrasser d'Hitler d'abord,
on allait avoir des problèmes très
comparables avec Staline après la guerre.
Mais à présent, à Yalta,
malgré la suspicion et les rancœurs,
les Alliés doivent former ensemble
le gouvernement de la future Pologne.
Tout l'enjeu est de savoir quelle entité
politique il faut prendre comme base.
Évidemment, du point
de vue des Anglo-Américains,
il faut construire
un gouvernement d'union nationale
à partir des différentes composantes
politiques de la Pologne antifasciste.
Du point de vue
des Soviétiques et de Staline,
il s'agit simplement de partir
de la base du gouvernement
tel qu'il existe à Varsovie
et d'ajouter quelques membres.
Un bras de fer s'engage.
Staline ne veut pas entendre
parler du gouvernement de Londres.
D'un autre côté, à chaque fois
que Churchill ou Roosevelt
font un pas vers lui
en proposant des personnalités
à faire entrer dans
le gouvernement de Lublin, il refuse.
Pourquoi accepterait-il ?
Staline sait qu'il est
en position de force.
Les troupes soviétiques
étaient dans ces pays.
Elles occupaient ces pays,
même si on n'osait pas
employer le mot occupation.
Quoi qu'il en soit,
elles étaient bien là.
D'une certaine manière, l'influence
de l'Union soviétique était inévitable.
Les Alliés ne parviennent
pas à s'entendre.
Petit à petit, le ton monte.
Staline est de plus en plus agité.
À ses côtés,
Ivan Maïsky est pétrifié.
Dans son journal, il raconte la scène.
« Soudain, Staline se leva et fit
de grands gestes avec son bras droit.
Un tel comportement lors
d'une conférence avec les trois grands
n'était pas vraiment approprié.
Il commença à parler
avec un énervement inhabituel. »
Staline est quelqu'un de très taciturne
et quelqu'un de très calme aussi,
sauf à quelques reprises
où il va s'énerver.
Du coup, ces moments-là
paraissent d'autant plus importants.
Le fait de se lever
et d'avoir tout d'un coup
une tirade très émotive sur un sujet,
c'est une manière de montrer
très clairement à ses interlocuteurs
les choses sur lesquelles
il n'y a rien à négocier.
La tirade du Soviétique
laisse ses alliés KO.
Hopkins, qui assiste à la catastrophe,
glisse alors un petit mot à Roosevelt,
qui préside les débats.
« Pourquoi ne pas en finir
avec ça aujourd'hui ?
Dites que nous en reparlerons
demain. Il est 19h15. »
Mieux vaut arrêter les frais
et tenter de repartir
sur de nouvelles bases le lendemain.
La maestria avec laquelle
Staline mène les négociations
saute aux yeux de tous.
Oncle Joe,
comme le surnomment les Occidentaux,
exerce un pouvoir
de fascination sur les délégations.
Le soir, dans sa chambre,
le diplomate Alexander Cadogan écrit :
« Oncle Joe est
le plus impressionnant des trois.
Il est très calme et réservé.
Quand il intervient,
il n'emploie jamais un mot superflu
et va droit au but. »
Le secrétaire d'État britannique
Anthony Eden n'est pas moins admiratif.
« Par des méthodes subtiles,
il obtient ce qu'il veut
sans avoir eu l'air de s'obstiner. ».
Pourtant, tout le mérite
de Staline ne peut être attribué
à son seul talent de négociateur.
Car ce que Eden
et Cadogan ignorent,
c'est qu'Oncle Joe fait
espionner ses alliés.
Avant même que
la conférence de Yalta ne s'ouvre,
il était au courant de tout.
La préparation de la conférence
de Yalta a duré plusieurs mois.
À l'époque, les services
de renseignements russes
étaient très bien implantés
en Angleterre et aux États-Unis.
Nos agents nous donnaient
des informations complètes
sur la manière dont Churchill et Roosevelt
se préparaient pour la conférence.
Nous savions sur quoi
et comment ils voulaient discuter
et quelle position ils allaient
défendre durant toutes les négociations.
Pour ne rien rater,
les services secrets russes ont
également truffé les palais de micros.
Ça, Churchill et Roosevelt le savent.
Ce qu'ils ne savent pas,
et là où ils sont naïfs,
c'est que, évidemment, pour les choses
confidentielles, ils sortent dans le parc.
Mais dans le parc, on a posé
les micros omnidirectionnels
qui sont partout.
Il y en a dans les arbres,
dans les frondaisons, dans les buissons...
et ils captent les conversations
à plusieurs mètres à la ronde.
Staline ne prend pas
ces écoutes à la légère.
Il ne veut pas en perdre une miette.
Il exige même que
ses espions viennent en personne
lui rapporter tout ce qui s'est dit.
Staline demandait de quelle façon
les choses s'étaient dites.
Il demandait même
qu'on lui répète les dialogues
avec l'intonation que Churchill
ou que Roosevelt avaient prise.
Dans la partie
de poker qui se joue à Yalta,
les cartes sont truquées.
Staline connaît le jeu de ses adversaires.
Il sait exactement où il va,
là où ses partenaires sont
dans l'obscurité et avancent à tâtons.
Au quatrième jour de négociations,
il faut finaliser le dossier polonais.
Grâce aux écoutes de la veille,
Staline sait que ses alliés sont
prêts à sacrifier la Pologne
pour faire aboutir d'autres
dossiers plus essentiels pour eux.
Pour Roosevelt, ce qui importe,
c'est l'ONU et le Japon.
Pour Churchill, c'est un dossier qui ne
sera jamais abordé directement à Yalta,
mais qui est sous-jacent,
celui de la Grèce.
Le pays est un ancien
protectorat britannique.
C'est un enjeu
stratégique pour les Anglais,
car la Grèce ouvre
la voie au canal de Suez
qui leur permet
d'accéder à leurs colonies.
Mais depuis deux ans, la Grèce est
en proie à une violente guerre civile.
Des communistes tentent
de renverser le roi.
Ils tiennent les campagnes
et sont aux portes du pouvoir.
Si la Grèce bascule dans le communisme,
c'est tout l'Empire
britannique qui sera menacé.
Churchill redoute
ce scénario catastrophe.
Pour l'éviter, il a donc pris les devants
et s'est livré à un marchandage périlleux.
En octobre 1944,
quatre mois avant Yalta,
le Premier ministre britannique a
rencontré Staline à Moscou,
en tête-à-tête.
Roosevelt était alors
en pleine campagne électorale
pour sa réélection.
Profitant de l'absence
du président américain,
Churchill a alors proposé
un accord secret sur l'Europe à Staline.
Quand on parle du partage du monde,
ce n'est pas à Yalta qu'il a eu lieu,
c'est à Moscou, quand Churchill
et Staline se sont rencontrés.
Le document,
griffonné sur un coin de table,
est écrit de la main
de Churchill et annoté par Staline.
Comme deux épiciers,
les dirigeants se sont chacun attribués
des pourcentages
d'influence en Europe de l'Est.
90 % pour la Russie en Roumanie,
75 % pour les Soviétiques en Bulgarie,
90 % pour la Grande-Bretagne en Grèce.
À Yalta, Churchill espère
que Staline tiendra compte de cet accord.
Et pour que le Soviétique lui
laisse les mains libres en Grèce,
le Premier ministre britannique est
prêt à lâcher du lest sur la Pologne.
Cet accord des pourcentages contraste
évidemment avec l'idée
d'un Churchill intransigeant
et qui n'aurait absolument
jamais voulu de compromis
sur la question de zones
ou de sphères d'influence en Europe.
Pour ne pas froisser Staline,
les Occidentaux finissent donc
par se montrer
conciliants sur la Pologne.
Au quatrième jour de négociations,
l'Américain et le Britannique lâchent
le gouvernement en exil de Raczkiewicz
et reconnaissent le gouvernement
communiste de Bierut à Lublin.
En contrepartie,
Churchill et Roosevelt obtiennent
que les ministres non communistes
entrent dans le gouvernement de Lublin.
Staline s'engage aussi à organiser
des élections libres
en Pologne après la guerre,
ainsi que dans tous les pays
libérés par l'Armée rouge.
Ce mot d' « élection libre » sonne
comme une victoire pour les Occidentaux,
même s'ils n'ont obtenu
aucune garantie de la part de Staline.
Tout ce qu'ils pouvaient tirer de Staline,
c'était des déclarations
de bonnes intentions et des formules
qui permettaient de sauver la face
devant leurs parlements respectifs.
Ils y sont à peu près arrivés.
Qu'est-ce qu'ils
pouvaient faire de plus ?
Mais comment imaginer
des élections libres
quand le territoire est complètement
occupé par les armées soviétiques ?
C'est là qu'il y a une illusion
de la part des Occidentaux.
Car en échange de ces promesses,
les Occidentaux accordent
une énorme faveur à Staline.
Ils lui permettent
de constituer son glacis protecteur
en rattachant une partie
de la Pologne à l'URSS.
En compensation, la Pologne récupérera
plus tard des territoires allemands.
Le pays effectuera ainsi
une translation vers l'ouest.
Dans le dossier polonais,
c'est le carton plein pour Staline.
Le Soviétique a obtenu
tout ce qu'il voulait.
Ses alliés espèrent à présent
que Staline saura s'en souvenir.
Ce 8 février, il fait un soleil
éclatant dans le ciel de Crimée.
Roosevelt est nerveux car les discussions
sur le Japon doivent commencer.
Le président américain a absolument
besoin de l'appui du Soviétique.
Pour mettre toutes
les chances de son côté,
Roosevelt invite alors Staline à partager
un Martini juste avant la séance plénière.
Churchill n'a pas été prévenu.
La rencontre entre les deux alliés
se déroule dans son dos.
Roosevelt craint
que l'impétueux Britannique
ne l'empêche de négocier
librement et ne fasse tout capoter.
Puis le président américain croit
aussi aux vertus du tête-à-tête.
Il croyait qu'il pouvait développer une
relation personnelle avec Joseph Staline.
Et je crois que Roosevelt sentait
qu'il pouvait influencer Staline
grâce à cette relation
privilégiée qu'il entretenait.
Mais ça, ça ne marche pas
avec les personnes comme Staline.
Il n'imaginait pas
à quel point Staline était cruel
et exempt de tout sentiment humain.
Au même moment, dans le Pacifique,
les Américains connaissent
des revers importants
face à une armée japonaise fanatisée.
Sans l'aide des Russes,
l'état-major américain a calculé
que la guerre pourrait durer encore un an
et coûter la vie à plus de 500 000 GI's.
Roosevelt est déterminé
à éviter ce bain de sang.
Staline le sait
et il fait monter les enchères.
En échange de la chair à canon
soviétique, il veut des territoires.
Et le maréchal est gourmand.
Il réclame
l'île Sakhaline et les îles Kouriles.
Mais aussi l'occupation
de Port-Arthur, Dairen,
et une voie de chemin
de fer en Mandchourie.
Les négociations ne portent pas
sur Sakhaline, ni sur les Kouriles,
parce que ça appartient au Japon
et les Américains sont tout à fait prêts
à donner du territoire japonais
aux Soviétiques.
Dairen et Port-Arthur, c'est plus embêtant
parce que ça appartient à la Chine.
La Chine, c'est Tchang Kaï-chek.
Tchang Kaï-chek,
c'est l'allié des États-Unis,
et il n'a pas été invité à Yalta.
Roosevelt peut donc se faire
reprocher, notamment par son Sénat,
de faire des concessions
à Staline aux dépens d'un allié.
Ça, c'est très embêtant.
Mais Staline tente
à son tour d'amadouer Roosevelt.
Avec son charme, il parviendra
bien à trouver une solution
et à faire accepter
les choses à Tchang Kaï-chek.
Charles Bohlen, l'interprète de Roosevelt,
rapporte dans ses mémoires :
« Staline dit qu'il était clair que
si ses conditions n'étaient pas réunies,
il lui serait difficile,
ainsi qu'à Molotov,
d'expliquer pourquoi l'Union soviétique
déclarerait la guerre au Japon.
Il est clair que Roosevelt était embêté
par cette situation. »
Roosevelt hésite.
Mais face à l'intransigeance
du Soviétique,
l'Américain ravale ses scrupules.
Ce qui compte pour lui,
c'est d'en finir avec cette guerre.
Va pour Dairen et Port-Arthur.
Roosevelt sacrifie les Chinois.
Il se débrouillera plus tard
avec Tchang Kaï-chek,
une fois la guerre terminée.
Le président américain
peut être satisfait.
Il a rempli ses objectifs.
Sur le Japon,
mais aussi sur l'ONU.
Cette nouvelle organisation
voulue par Roosevelt
a pour ambition
de garantir la paix dans le monde.
Staline a donné son accord
de principe pour y prendre part.
La participation effective
de l'URSS est loin d'être acquise,
mais c'est déjà un premier pas.
C'est une grosse concession
de lui faire admettre qu'il va
envoyer Molotov à Dumbarton Oaks
pour les négociations préliminaires.
Même ça, c'est une grande
concession de la part de Staline.
Staline n'arrête pas de dire :
« Si ça se trouve, votre truc
de l'ONU, je n'en voudrais pas.
Est-ce que je vais
envoyer Molotov ou pas ?
Il sait très bien en jouer.
C'est un artiste.
Sixième jour de négociations.
Ce 9 février 1945,
Churchill, Roosevelt
et Staline peuvent afficher
leur bonne humeur devant les caméras.
ONU, Japon, Allemagne,
Pologne : sur tous ces dossiers,
les trois grands ont trouvé des compromis
et chacun a obtenu
ce qui lui importait le plus.
Churchill s'est imposé
comme un égal face aux deux grands.
Il a hissé la France
dans le camp des vainqueurs.
Il lui a fait attribuer
une zone d'occupation en Allemagne.
Le président américain,
lui, a obtenu le feu vert de Staline
sur l'ONU et sur le Japon.
Avec Churchill, il a aussi arraché
à Staline la promesse d'organiser
des élections libres en Pologne
et en Europe de l'Est après la guerre.
Mais c'est le maréchal
soviétique qui rafle la mise.
Incontestablement,
c'est l'Union soviétique et Staline
qui sortent vainqueurs
de cette conférence de Yalta.
Staline a obtenu
ce qu'il souhaitait concernant la Pologne
et il a obtenu plus ou moins ce
qu'il souhaitait concernant l'Allemagne,
en tout cas, le principe des réparations.
L'image d'une entente parfaite entre
les trois grands fera le tour du monde.
Elle est pourtant trompeuse.
À Yalta, Staline, Roosevelt et Churchill
ont fait en sorte de s'entendre.
Ils voulaient préserver l'Alliance,
alors que la guerre
n'était toujours pas terminée.
Mais dans le fond, chacun d'eux
a défendu sa vision du monde
et ses intérêts propres.
Les accords de Yalta sont précaires.
Ils sont le fruit de compromis
et ne reposent que sur l'entente fragile
entre trois personnalités d'exception.
Au dernier jour des négociations,
pourtant, chacun veut y croire.
Dans la soirée,
les délégations portent des toasts
à l'amitié entre les peuples
et à la paix de l'humanité.
Mais cet espoir ne va durer
que peu de temps.
L'entente que les trois grands
célèbrent va bientôt voler en éclats.
À peine trois semaines
après la fin de la conférence,
Staline viole les accords de Yalta.
En Roumanie, alors que l'Armée
rouge occupe toujours le pays,
il organise la prise
de pouvoir par les communistes.
En Pologne,
à chaque fois que ses alliés proposent
un nom de ministre non communiste
à faire entrer au gouvernement,
Staline le refuse.
Roosevelt, jusque-là
si confiant, prend peur.
Après Yalta, Roosevelt
a commencé à déchanter.
Il s'est aperçu
que le Staline qu'il imaginait
ne correspondait pas
tout à fait au véritable Staline.
Le 1ᵉʳ avril,
le président américain envoie
un long télégramme
à son cher Staline
afin d'obtenir des explications.
« Je ne peux vous cacher
l'inquiétude que j'éprouve
devant la manière dont se déroulent,
depuis notre fructueuse
rencontre de Yalta,
des événements
où nos intérêts communs sont en jeu.
Franchement, je ne peux comprendre
pourquoi les événements récents
en Roumanie devraient être considérés
comme ne tombant pas
sous les termes de notre accord.
Mais les mises en garde de Roosevelt
n'émeuvent aucunement Staline.
Sans le moindre scrupule,
le Soviétique déroule son plan
et continue à installer
des régimes communistes à l'est.
Roosevelt s'éteint 11 jours
après l'envoi de son télégramme.
Il ne verra jamais
l'ampleur de la trahison.
Churchill, qui, à la surprise générale,
perdra les élections en Angleterre,
devra assister,
impuissant et seul, à leur échec.
À Yalta, les trois grands
n'auront pas donné naissance
à ce monde de paix tant espéré.
Le rêve de fraternité
n'aura été qu'un leurre.
Bientôt, les alliés d'hier
deviendront ennemis,
s'affrontant lors d'un conflit
d'un nouveau genre :
la guerre froide.